what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I wanted to kind of relaunch
this chemical concepts idea which is to
say where we go through and just talk
about these things that have a place
within the realm of Marvel Comics but
don't really fall in the category of
like character explanations but don't
really fall in the category of team
explanations either either it's because
there's so little information about them
or because they only really ever had one
notable thing or something along those
lines but in this video we're gonna be
talking about the Black Order of Thanos
now the Black Order of Thanos was
basically revealed during Disney's d23
weekend which is an event that they put
on every two years where they basically
showcase all the upcoming projects that
exist under the Disney banner of course
Star Wars having them been bought by
Disney we end up seeing a lot of Star
Wars stuff and with Marvel having been
bought by Disney a lot of the models
Cinematic Universe stuff is thrown under
there and while there was a trailer
released for infinity war which has not
been made public Disney also Choa case
to everybody that the black order is
gonna be part of infinity war now the
black order being rolled in to infinity
war is a pretty big deal and the reason
why is because it shows us just how
capable and how much of a demagogue
Thanos is and the sense that he can
basically rally people to his cause but
in Marvel Comics the black order is
actually really new they appeared as
part of Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
new avengers leading into Secret Wars
2015 and so the result was that the
black order simply just served the
purpose of helping fan OHS and invading
the planet Earth now want you to keep in
mind is that the black order are not
like equal to Thanos like it's not like
there are Thanos as friends there are
basically servants they exist to serve
the whims of Thanos but the reason why
this is so cool is because what we're
not given a whole lot of history between
them which is to say we're not really
given the origin stories of the Black
Order we're not really told where they
come from we do know what each
individual member is capable of and we
also know that it's both fear and
admiration as well as a desire to
basically inflict as much destruction
and conflict as they possibly can as
well as bolster their own level of power
which is why they allied themselves with
Thanos in the first place but the first
member of the of the Black Order that I
want to have a discussion on here is
actually a guy by the name of Corvus
glaive and the way the Black Order works
is that Corvus glaive is essentially
like the leader so to speak of the Black
Order in the sense that he's like the
right-hand man of Thanos he's the one
that serves alongside the will of Thanos
and basically implements his will as far
as what it is the black
is going to do but Corvus glaive is kind
of like this military tactician who's an
absolute genius
in almost every form of combat which is
to say when he goes to invade a planet
he studies all forms of warfare that
planet has ever engaged in and then it
figures out the best way to invade that
planet in the best way to attack it now
the way this comes out is that he
basically has you know superhuman
strength speed durability endurance
nothing wildly insane he's not able to
like manipulate reality or anything
along those lines and that's what we're
gonna find with most these members of
the Black Order is that in comparison to
the power of Thanos they just don't have
the same kind of thing that he does but
Corvus glaive does have immortality
insofar that he carries a blade with him
and so long as the blade is never
destroyed he will always end up staying
alive the reason why this matters is
because during the events of Thanos his
invasion of Earth there came a point
where Corvus glaive body was totally
incinerated but because of the fact that
his sphere was kept intact when the son
of Thanos encased Thanos himself as well
as Proxima midnight in this sort of a
amber container in order to remove them
from being villains or anything like
that
Corvus glaive sword was encased as well
and he actually simply began to
regenerate because of the fact that the
sword keeps him alive now we're not told
explicitly why we're simply just kind of
told that's the way that it is and so it
really just kind of seems to be this
idea that the sword has some essence of
a soul inside of it or something along
those lines but we just kind of have to
take it for what it is something else to
point out here is that when Thanos and
the Black Order arrived on earth and
Corvus glaive was tasked alongside the
other members of the Black Order to
basically seek out and combat the
different superhero teams with the
Avengers you know basically being off
planet Corvus glaive led an onslaught
against the x-men and completely wrecked
to them I mean you just totally
dominated them he was unbelievable there
was where was one of the craziest things
that was basically nothing the x-men
could do to overcome the forces of
Corvus glaive I remember it's not
because Corvis he has powers it's
because he's such a good you know
strategist when it comes to military
tactics and so on now following Corvus
glaive becomes Proxima midnight again
the wife of Corvus glaive and the idea
here is that Proxima midnight served as
the black order but also has a different
set of abilities to a degree than the
Corvus himself now again we're not
giving the backstory of how they ended
up coming together but with the idea of
a Proxima midnight her role in the
invasion of Earth came alongside
basically her her goal in uh in tracking
down atlantis and then basically forcing
him with a submariner
to bend a knee to the will of Thanos now
she comes with like invulnerability and
strength speed endurance more or less
the same thing as Corvus glaive but
she's also a master combatant the
difference here is that she actually has
a spear that allows her to basically cut
through almost anything basically cut
things down to a molecular level and so
again it's one of the most notable
aspects of her character because her
ability to use this weapon can affect
different biological beings different
ways one of the most notable of this is
when she fought the Incredible Hulk and
during that story during the the events
of infinity when she attacked the
Incredible Hulk with her spear it forced
the Incredible Hulk to revert back to
Bruce Banner one of the things that
wasn't explained is why we don't know
for example if it's like the
relationship between vibranium and
Colossus Colossus of course if he's
exposed to vibranium his organic metal
skin will immediately recede whether he
wants it to or not and he'll go back
into his human form we don't know if it
was the exact same way with the
Incredible Hulk when Proxima midnight
attacked him and an Incredible Hulk just
receded and Bruce Banner came out we
don't really know what the case was all
we know is that that basically just kind
of happened there but it was a really
good way for Marvel to sort of introduce
the concept in and then in turn make her
a more notable character otherwise she
would have been a pretty useless member
of the team but one of the most notable
individuals who were part of the Black
Order is actually someone by the name of
ebony maw now the funny thing about
ebony maw is that he can delve into
magics and sorcery the most impressive
display of ebony moss abilities came in
the form of him dominating Doctor
Strange and that's one of the craziest
things here because remember Doctor
Strange is a multiversal entity I mean
he's a guy who's powerful enough to
influence the multiverse I mean classic
Doctor Strange the version of Doctor
Strange that we had before the 1990s was
one of the most powerful beings to have
ever existed in the history of Marvel
Comics but even after Marvel deep Howard
him took away a large portion of what it
was that he was capable of in order to
try to make him more relatable he was
still wildly powerful and the ebony maw
popping up and basically dominating the
mind of Doctor Strange turning him into
a pawn
and foresee dr. strange to release Shuma
gorath who's like this multi-dimensional
you know enemy that's insanely powerful
it's just a display of just how capable
the ebony maw is now in Vadim ah in turn
also influenced the son of Thanos Thane
to basically turn against his father and
encase his father an amber in the first
place and so again it's really kind of
cool to see this character being
introduced into infinity war because the
ebony MA would basically be an enemy of
dr. strange it could very well turn into
a circumstance where the infinity war
event breaks out and dr. strange is
powerless to stop evany MA that's the
kind of the level of strength that we're
dealing with here now over the course of
the events of vengers and New Avengers
leading up to secret Wars we ended up
learning that dr. strange actually
wasn't using 100% of his power when he
faced off against evany MA
and said it was really more of like
tactics and subversion in the sense of
ebony ma snuck up on Doctor Strange
influenced his mind
but even then Doctor Strange actually
sold 100% of his soul for all power in
existence for absolute power which is
something that happened later on down
the line when the Illuminati basically
Marvel's New Avengers faced off against
what passes from Allah's version of the
Justice League more or less but it was
still kind of a cool situation because
we're still talking about a guy who was
able to overpower a pretty capable being
I mean the ebony maw being able to
overpower dr. strange is a pretty big
deal because despite the fact that he
wasn't using 100% of his power he should
still have been perfectly aware of
events that were going on all around him
you know on the fact that ebony ma could
sneak up on a guy who has tool up at the
intellicus and you know the ability to
see the future to a degree and
everything's like that is a testament to
what it was that he was able to pull off
now moving on to black dwarf he's really
not as interesting as some of the others
because black dwarf is basically just
like the strong guy of the team and
that's really it I mean there's really
not much going on in terms of what it is
a black horse capable of during the
original invasion of Earth by Thanos
through the events of infinity black
dwarf was actually tasked with invading
Wakanda and taking out Black Panther the
funny thing about this is that because
Wakanda was so technologically advanced
black dwarf actually found a lot of
resistance by the wakandans themselves
specifically from Black Panther and the
midnight angels now the midnight angels
are basically Black Panthers inner
circle of the most capable warriors who
are all women and it's a really cool
concept because they are a four
to behold when it comes to any major
combat scenario and we've actually saw a
couple previews of them during the the
Black Panther trailer I don't know if
you noticed them but they were basically
the bald women they were the ones who
seemed to stand in like military
positions and seem to hold positions of
power The Midnight Angels basically you
know study almost every conceivable form
of martial arts some of which are
basically like these martial arts that
originated in Wakanda or are an
amalgamation of other martial arts
styles combined into one so again
they're pretty formidable this combined
with all the different forms of
technological advancements that Wakanda
had meant that when black dwarf tried to
invade Wakanda he was basically fought
off and he was ultimately defeated and
then actually cast out of the Black
Order by Thanos now none of us really
mattered because eventually later on he
was destroyed by Ron and the accuser but
in terms of the model Cinematic Universe
black dwarf looks like he would be more
of a character that would be paired up
against like four or the Incredible Hulk
or something like that it would make
sense that that would be the case now
the other half of this is that with the
infinity war of improper Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet is gonna have so much
power that Thor in the Incredible Hulk
wouldn't even stand much of a chance in
the first place but again including
black dwarf in the events of infinity
war is gonna be kind of interesting
because having him fight alongside his
brother Corvus glaive and his
sister-in-law Proxima midnight is gonna
be kind of a funny situation again
assuming they keep those familiar
relationships intact now this brings us
to supergiant and this is one of the the
funny situations about this is because
what supergiant does is basically
fulfill the nature of the Infinity
stones themselves when it comes to
supergiant with in Marvel Comics she was
a character that basically had the
ability to dominate the minds of others
which is to say she could control their
minds in their entirety she could
basically make them do anything that she
wanted to do regardless of who they were
or even what their their capabilities
were in terms of maintaining blocks
against psychic attacks now when it
comes to characters who were like Omega
level telepaths was just a saying the
most powerful kinds of telepaths in the
Marvel Universe Emma Frost Charles
Xavier things like that they could
probably resist it but when it came to
like Black Bolt
of the Inhumans he was basically used by
supergiant to attack the Avengers in the
Illuminati and basically ward them off
now of course she ended up meeting her
defeat when bombs were activated by a
black vulture brother Maximus than that
which resulted in her destruction but
the fact remains she played a
every small role I mean she really
wasn't that huge that impactful during
the events of of infinity instead she
was just kind of there for a little
while and then she engaged in a couple
things here and there and that was
really about it I mean there really
wasn't a whole lot of it that she added
to it but something that I hope you guys
notice is that for the most part these
members of the Black Order all represent
aspects of the Infinity stones when it
comes to like the Power Stone for
example the stone that represents
absolute power strengths energy
projection different things like that
that could easily be manifested in the
form of black dwarf when it comes to
using tactics when it comes to using the
ability to manipulate individuals into
achieving certain goals or recognizing
the environment around them the reality
stone for example that could be
manifested in the form of Corvus glaive
when it comes to all these different
aspects they all tie in to the nature of
the black order themselves but it also
begs the question what role will the
Black Order serve when it comes to
infinity war honestly I would say
they're just gonna be the first front
attack they're gonna be the first
individuals that the Avengers face off
against or at least all the heroes that
are going to be there it's gonna be the
sort of taste of things that are going
to be coming later on down the line and
it sort of makes sense because during
the original Infinity Gauntlet story it
was almost like the opposite he was
basically Adam warlock mustering the
forces of those superheroes who weren't
killed when Thanos blinked out half the
life in the universe and it was Thanos
facing off against that first line of
superheroes ultimately it was revealed
to be a distraction and Adam warlock
actually had this whole conflict going
on so that in a moment of arrogance
Thanos would let his guard down and the
Silver Surfer could steal the Infinity
Gauntlet which he failed to do but the
second role that Adam warlock put into
play was basically the cosmic entities
that Thanos had to face off against
infinity war and the black order seemed
to be the opposite that the Avengers are
gonna face off against the black order
first most likely they're gonna be
successful
they're gonna overpower them which is
gonna lead to them facing off against
Thanos directly and that's when things
are gonna get absolutely crazy and
absolutely hairy because we're gonna see
Thanos basically manipulating all space
and time and crazy crazy things probably
throwing planets around no idea but it's
gonna get absolutely bonkers in terms of
the power that we're gonna see ah but
but again the black order in Marvel
comics are basically the lieutenants of
Thanos and that was really it there
wasn't really a whole lot to them
besides that some of them lived on some
of them continue to go on for example
Corvus glaive re-emerged
an all-new all-different marvel in the
Fano solo series Proxima midnight
continued on it's part of Thanos his
cabal alongside name on the Submariner
and a handful of others but that was
really about it the other members of the
Black Order were basically all killed
off supergiant the ebony mob well the
ebony maw survived and came out an
all-new all-different marvel but
supergiant black dwarf they were all
basically obliterated you know during
the events of infinity so again it'll be
an interesting scenario to see how
things unfold I'm pretty excited for it
it's just kind of a interesting
situation to bring them in but in any
event if you guys are new here to come
this explain and you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you hit the sub button
to become part of the Rob core and make
sure you hit the like button if you dug
this and yeah pretty wide and bring this
video to an end and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]